[Musique]
le tour de france c'était son obsession
depuis toujours sa vocation son rêve de
gosse c'était de le couvrir en tant que
journaliste et de le commenter en tant
que spécialiste il a fait les deux et il
a fait même mieux il a fini par le
diriger 15 ans qu'il est le patron de la
grande boucle l'un des événements
sportifs les plus populaires de france
le troisième le plus regardé au monde
après les jo et la coupe du monde de
foot c'est lui qui sillonnent le pays
toute l'année pour choisir le tracé
déterminer les étapes décidé dé route
qu'emprunteront les coureurs et il a
fait ça avec fougue avec passion
certains le surnomment le chirac du
cyclisme parce qu'ils l'aiment cette
france qu'il rencontre au travers des
élus et des habitants mais alors que
répond-il à ceux qui trouvent le tour de
france un peu ringard à ceux qui pensent
que l'épreuve a peut-être fait son temps
et qu'elle n'est suivie que par des
seniors on va lui poser toutes ces
questions bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenue christian prudhomme et
merci d'être avec nous faire mieux si
spécial ce dôme tournant du sénat c'est
vrai ça qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ces jeunes qu'ils nous disent que le
tour est devenu ou est ringard et qui
laissa à leurs aînés que la deuxième
tranche d'âge qui a le plus regardé le
dernier tour de france sont les 15 24
ans donc je pense pas qu'il soit encore
totalement sénile mais vous l'entendez
ça c'est bien sûr mais moins c'est ces
deux ou trois dernières années aussi
sans doute parce que la façon de courir
des champions a évolué et que on est
sortis d'un système de catenaccio comme
on dirait dans le foot un cyclisme ces
attaques de beaucoup plus loin et donc
où ça plaît évidemment davantage la
bicyclette est non seulement à la mode
non seulement tendance mais c'est une
nouvelle façon de vivre un nouveau mode
de vie peut-être même pour certains et
certaines un nouvel art de vivre est ce
que nous voyons là en france existe dans
les pays limitrophes depuis bien plus
longtemps beaucoup de pays voit le tour
de france non seulement comme la plus
grande compétition cycliste monde mais
comme comme une sorte de locomotive pour
la pratique de la bicyclette quotidien
et pour nous français l'âge d'or du
cyclisme c'était quand les champions
sortait des fermes que faisait-il les
gamins les gamins qui sortait des fermes
hills et le concours de la de la plaque
d'entrée de communes et il est un sprint
donc les champions sont nés comme ça à
l'ailé bernal et raymond poulidor bien
sûr fils de métayer et bernard thévenet
élevés dans une ferme qui s'appelait
le guidon je vous le donne en mille le
guide dont
il était prédestiné c'est bernard
hinault qui ensuite étaient agriculteurs
mais voilà toute cette france là c'était
des gens qui naturellement aller à
bicyclette à l'école quand même jusque
dans les années 70 le cyclisme était
effectivement le sport le plus populaire
de france dans les années 60 l'écrivain
et journaliste antoine blondin disait
ceci le général de gaulle est le
président des français onze mois sur
douze en juillet c'est jacques goddet et
je précise jacques goddet qui était le
directeur du tour de 36 à 87 vous êtes
metrics n'est plus vraiment ça vous ne
vous sentez pas le président de la
france au mois de juillet absolument pas
en revanche il ya un très beau
documentaire qui est passé d'ailleurs
sur public sénat de nombreuses reprises
la réplique de juillet qui dit bien ou 6
quel tour de france le tour ce sont 3500
kilomètres de sourire ce sont des gens
banc de la route
ddd des jeunes des anciens des femmes
des hommes des français des étrangers
qui ont tous le sourire 3500 kilomètres
c'est la distance du tour de sourire des
gens heureux insouciant dans un monde
qui ne l'est pas du tout mais quand le
tour passe est souvent souvient
parfaitement de jours douloureux mais on
se souvient aussi du jour on a vu passer
le tour avec ses parents avec ses
cousins avec ses amis avec des copains
et des copines un spectacle gratuit en
plus totalement gratuit au bord des
routes bien évidemment la caravane qui
passe et les champions ensuite est-ce
que c'est un sujet pour vous au
quotidien d'essayer de le moderniser son
perdre l'essence premières de cette
épreuve oui bien sûr alors ça joue
énormément à travers la télévision bien
sûr les images du tour de france
france télévisions étant ce qu on
appelle le radiodiffuseur hôte donc
produisant les images avec amaury sport
organisation ces images par dont 190
pays sert quand on voit le tour partout
la chance de beaucoup me balader comme
quand je vais en australie près
d'adélaïde où a lieu une course cycliste
je vois les gens avec les aînés les bobs
des partenaires du tour de france les
gens me reconnaissent ils savent ce
qu'elles tour on vous parle du tour de
france absolument partout donc
de le moderniser toujours bien sûr mais
largement encore une fois à travers
alors j'allais dire la télévision la
captation en direct la télé la télé
d'aujourd'hui netflix qui arrivent et
cdd série vous voir tout ce qu'on ne
voit pas nécessairement peut-être pas
uniquement la retransmission donner de
la chair au champion ce que la presse
écrite ou la radio faisait
magnifiquement autre fois j'ai une part
de mystère aujourd'hui les étapes sont
toutes retransmise du premier au dernier
kilomètre il ya peut-être moins de
mystère ou sentiment qu'ils amendent
mystère et ça c'est la construction du
mythe en tout cas pour moi qui ai aimé
le tour largement grâce à la radio c'est
quelque chose de très important mais il
ya des choses que vous avez envie de
moderniser la leçon le son le son le son
le son mais je disais déjà quand j'étais
journaliste c'est tout le monde le pense
après il ya une vraie difficulté c'est à
dire entendre dans dans une étape de
plaine qui peut sembler lancinante il ya
une bagarre terrible au sein du peloton
que l'on ne voit pas les traversées
d'agglomérations avec tous les ronds
points les retours de trottoirs les
séparateurs de chaussée il faut être un
funambule pour rester debout dans les
étapes du tour de france il y à des
chutes il pourrait y en avoir encore
bien plus donc tout ça je rêverais qu'on
puisse l'entendre
or on ne l'entend pas et on ne voit pas
la bagarre qui existe au sein du peloton
dans ses essais c'est un événement
sonore le droit sans aucun doute sans
aucun doute bien sûr le bruit des freins
qui fait que vous citez vous ne citez
pas parce que vous avez entendu quelque
chose quand vous êtes en 20e ou en 30e
position dans un peloton où êtes aveugle
mais il pas ce qui se passe devant donc
les courants se repère beaucoup pour son
cd plus jeune âge un vous que vous avez
un coup de coeur pour le tour de france
je parlais de vocations presque une
mission quelque chose qui vous a que
vous avez chevillée au corps depuis
depuis toujours quand ça arrive dans
votre livre pourquoi ça arrive dans ma
vie ben grâce à mon père parce qu'avec
mon frère ma soeur on écoutait
énormément le tour de france à la radio
faut bien voir que je suis né en 1960 le
sont absolument oui parce que c'est ça
vous fait rêver je passais d'inter à rtl
de rtl rmc de rmc europe puisque il y
avait les flashs horaires ou les flashs
au sommet des cols donc quand vous êtes
gamin vous avez votre champion qui passe
en troisième position au sommet d'un col
vous dites est ce qu'il va revenir en
tête est-ce qu'il va tomber pourvu
qu'ils ne tombent pas un nom bien tout
cet imaginaire qui se construit petit à
petit et ça ça a été absolument
formidable pour moi il y avait toute une
c'était ma journée j'allais chercher ça
ne s'invente pas à nous nous battions
avec mon frère pour être le premier à
aller chercher l'équipe le matin et le
libraire s'appelait monsieur godet avec
un soldat ryan créateur de l'équipe et
patron du tour pendant 50 ans jacques
goddet avait donné donc on se battait
pour être le premier à récupérer
l'équipe et nous ne voulions surtout à
vélo vous il dit non non c'est plus
intéressant que chez nous au bas de la
rue et nous ne voulions surtout pas tout
lire le matin il fallait en garder pour
l'après midi je lisais pierre chany
journalistes célèbres du cyclisme à
l'équipe le matin mais je gardais en
tout cas mme blandin pour l'après midi
juste avant la retransmission télé il
fallait surtout pas que j'ai trop le
matin pour entre les flashs la radio
etc ça occupait tout mon univers et
quand la course était finie dans l'étape
était fini on a forcé une bicyclette et
on faisait le tour du pâté maison et
c'est pour commenter le tout ouïe
commenté le temps que vous devenez
journalistes que en fait je suis un des
études de journalisme je suis devenu
journaliste grâce au tour j'ai eu envie
de témoins un joris témoins qui
racontent ce que les autres ne peuvent
pas voir après le hasard de la vie a
fait que lorsque j'étais étudiant à
l'école de journalisme de lille
notre prof de radio qui s'appelle michel
scellier qui était correspondant rtl
dans le nord m'a dit avant les vacances
de pâques avant de sortir est ce que tu
es déjà les alarmes et a fait l'armée du
lit et donc il y avait une place à rtl
que je n'aurais pas eu sans doute si je
n'avais pas fait mon service avant
l'époque des glorieux anciens où on
partait à l'armée et ça a commencé comme
ça donc j'ai été dans le service des
sports de guy djediat à rtl et puis
ensuite ça a rebondi et c'est jusqu'à
france télévisions retrace les parcours
parce que vous avez aussi fait vos
débuts à télé match c'est ça qui était
alors le journal des sports de l'a5
exactement et pierre saint john et jenny
exactement ensuite vous allez être
journal sportif pour france télévisions
vous allez y mais stade 2 au début des
années 2000
passerait aussi par eurosport europe1
lci est ce que cette expérience
médiatique fait de vous aussi un patron
du tour qui fait de l'événement autre
chose qu'un événement sportif un
événement médiatique est ce que vous
avez ce regard là de l'homme de médias
je ne sais pas quelles sont les qualités
nécessaires pour être directeur du tour
ce que je sais en revanche c'est que si
on ne connaît rien à la communication
c'est impossible parfois on me dit mais
tu sais tu regrettes pas des deux de ne
plus être journaliste et je répond
inlassablement je n'ai jamais croisé
autant de journalistes que depuis je ne
suis plus j'en avais je suis toujours
avec les journalistes vous avez en fait
de faire de cet événement d'événements
télégénique en tête je ne sais pas mais
mais bien sûr je suis un journaliste par
vocation je n'avais jamais imaginé faire
autre chose que journaliste parce que
c'est le métier de ma vie ce que je fais
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas un métier c'est
une mission c'est vrai c'est vraiment
différent pompe c'est mon métier alors
naturellement que je sais ce que ça veut
dire que la prise de vue aérienne
dominante du tour le canton va choisir
un parcours du tour naturellement il est
l'aspect sportif déterminant avec une
équipe d'anciens couronne d'anciens
coureurs du tour à mes côtés mais
qu'ensuite ce convoi d'en haut les
paysages le patrimoine c'est quelque
chose d'absolument essentiel et le lien
social que craie le tour de france aussi
la au ras du sol c'est à dire faire en
sorte qu'on aille partout le tour de
france continue à aller partout on nous
reproche de partir de l'étranger mais je
le revendique totalement en revanche le
tour de france ce sont des très grandes
villes françaises et étrangères des
villes moyennes et des petits villages
quand on part de castelnau magnoac dans
les hautes pyrénées et chez antoine
dupont capitaine du quinze de france ça
veut dire quelque chose quand on va à
loudenvielle et ses 300 habitants quand
on va à saran évidemment connu pour
jacques chirac ou bernadette chirac mais
quand on y va ça veut dire quelque chose
le tour c'est ça il faut qu'on puisse
aller partout l'événement des
territoires où on va y venir évidemment
je vais rester un tout petit peu encore
sur le côté médiatique si vous voulez
bien vous donne en g2 archives pour vous
alors c'est une exception d'habitude on
en a qu'une mais là les archives
nationales nous ont confié deux c'est
une planche de photos qui datent de 1964
c'est le moment de la présentation du
nouveau matériel de la rti la radio
télévision française un matériel vu
comme perfectionner à l'époque j'imagine
complètement dépassés aujourd'hui où
finalement les choses n'ont pas tant
changé que cela entre 1904 et
aujourd'hui de ce point de vue
techniques médiatiques ça a énormément
changé mais en revanche je la plus
profonde gratitude pour celles et ceux
qui ont fait que ça peut aujourd'hui
existe est telle que c'est se dire que
le tour est un événement qui a des
racines j'ai toujours peur quand les
gens n'ont pas de racines quand ils ont
oublié avant moi rien n'existait après
moi le déluge ça ça ne fait pas partie
du tour de france ça qu'il faut savoir
ce qui s'est passé avant nous et
pourquoi et pourquoi le tour est ce
qu'il est sans les comme pionnier ming
coppi bartali 100/100 louison bobet sans
jacques anquetil séance en bernard
hinault sans raymond poulidor sans eddy
merckx le tour ne serait pas ce qu'il
est donc c'est la même chose aussi pour
ça sert qu être capable de 2,2 de
montrer le tour en direct 1 d'abord
c'était juste après guerre avec la
l'arrivée au parc des princes l'ancien
parc des princes
ensuite j'aime assez c'est assez les
premiers passages au sommet des cols col
d'aubisque
entre-autres pyrénées et pyrénées
atlantiques tout ça c'est la légende du
tour j'aurais vrai que dans deux ans
trois ans 5 ans 10 ans puisse dire à ma
leçon avant c'était pas terrible et
maintenant c'est merveilleux moi qui
suis un gamin encore une fois des années
60 la fameuse finale saint-etienne
bayern de foot de 76 finale de la coupe
d'europe des clubs champions on parlait
pas de ligue des champions on a bien vu
les tirs sur la barre et sur les poteaux
on n'a pas entendu le bruit depuis
trente ans on entend un corner un coup
franc une entrée en mêlée en foot ou au
rugby et le son dans le vélo n'a pas
beaucoup progressé alors que l'image est
phénoménal c'est un défi technique à
chaque fois oui ça défi technique parce
que c'est pas un circuit de formule 1 ou
2 motos ses 200 km d'une ville à l'autre
et je voudrais vous donner sept autres
archives puisque vous parliez du parc
des princes j'avoue que je l' ai
découvert en préparant ces trois
l'accident avec vous non c'est
effectivement c'est arrivé au parc des
princes que j'ignorais dont c'est une
planche de photos des coureurs du tour
de france 2009 163 là que vous voyez est
on le sait peu mais 54 édition se sont
terminées au parc des princes pourquoi
ça s'est arrêté jusqu'en 1967 pour
innocent très simple c'est qu'il ya plus
de vélodrome au parc des princes et que
donc
la derniers jours du tour de france a
quitté l'ouest de paris pour l'est est
allé s'installer pendant une demi
douzaine d'années à la cipale dans le
bois de vincennes avant qu'à partir de
1975 valéry giscard d'estaing yves bot
si les patrons du tour félix lévitan
jacques goddet ne fasse en sorte qu'il
arrive sur les champs elysées terme et
décidé par les politiques ça je ne sais
pas parce qu'il ya une bagarre dans tout
ce qu'on peut entendre en trichant
mourousi qui était donc le présentateur
vedette du 13h valéry giscard d'estaing
président de la république félix lévitan
co directeur du tour de france quoi
qu'il en soit il peut importe c'est
arrivé sur les champs elysées en 75 gt
gt sur place avec ma mère et ma soeur à
la sortie du métro depuis drire garé
dans la rue de rivoli et nous avons vu
ce jour est arrivé deux coureurs
échappés le champion du monde et
diverses le plus champion de liste plus
grands champions de l'histoire est dans
sa roue est sans doute mort de trouille
le maillot jaune bernard thévenet qui
allait donc battre et diverses et
lillers essayant jusqu'au bout de
reprendre la première place c'était
absolument facile et après que vous
diriez que l'arrivée sur les
champs-elysées a fait de cet événement
un événement encore plus mythique voire
mythique tout court sans le moindre
doute mais vous savez à quoi donc ah oui
oui bien évidemment parce que c'est une
carte postale phénoménal vous êtes les
coureurs sont dans la carte postale sur
les champs-elysées vous voir les champs
elysées alors c'était évidemment
complètement fou à l'époque vides
y avait deux jours le 14 juillet l'armée
et le jour de l'arrivée du tour de
france avec les coureurs du tour de
france c'est juste phénoménal bien sûr
et à quoi une arrivée devant le sénat la
chambre des territoires
c'est un événement des territoires nous
sommes passés devant le sénat il y avait
d'ailleurs eu des études pour que nous
passions à l'intérieur du sénat la
difficulté c'est qu'évidemment c'est pas
goudronnées à l'intérieur même si on a
pu le faire au plateau de glières pour
des raisons d' histoire bien évidemment
en haute-savoie ya quelques années mais
ça a été étudié et vous savez le sénat
est un lieu très important pour la
démocratie française mais pour nous
organisateurs du tour aussi puisque
avaient été créés grâce à françois
fortassin ancien président du conseil
général à l'époque les hautes-pyrénées
et sénateur des hautes pyrénées les amis
du tour qui maintenant sont regroupés
dans le groupe sport et culture avec
michel savin avec gilbert boucher avec
d'autres sénateurs et sénatrices mais
qui sont des fidèles du tour et j'en
vois toujours avec un immense plaisir et
pour cause alors ce tour comment vous le
préparez vous préparé minutieusement
vous le préparez jeu tous les jours de
l'année donc nous travaillons sur trois
éditions consécutives
du tour de france en permanence donc il
ya ce qu'on appelle le grand départ le
départ du tour de france à qui et en
général et dévoiler tous deux ans avant
la date est donc ça ça nécessite
évidemment un certain nombre de
rendez-vous de déplacement etc et puis
du lieu du grand départ découle un
parcours sachant que les alpes et les
pyrénées sont incontournables en fait il
y a beaucoup de figures imposées entre
ce que les contraintes de l'union
cycliste internationale des contraintes
sportives réglementaire la géographie de
la france qui est essentiel si vous
tracez une droite du pays basque au nord
de l'alsace toute la partie montagneuse
et est à l'est donc mais il faut quand
même qu'on aille à l'ouest la bretagne
et fille aînée du cyclisme la vendée
adore le tour la normandie et le nord
aussi donc il ya cette répartition là ça
ne peut pas être simplement un choix
purement sportif même si l'événement
sportif est naturellement déterminant il
faut que le tour de france puisse aller
partout en cinq ou six ans mais c'est
d'aller au moins une fois dans chacune
des régions c'est le casse tête où vous
avez même des doutes sur le tracé qui a
été choisi finalement non parce qu'il ya
toujours un tour après le tour donc
c'est pas
impliqué puis la fois d'après ce sera
dans son temps c'est un an après deux
ans après et d'ailleurs on travaille
beaucoup nous ne travaillons beaucoup
évidemment on a la chance d'avoir 300
candidatures pour une trentaine de
places dans les 300 candidatures vous
avez une douzaine une quinzaine de
départements de conseils départementaux
ce qui veut dire que c'est pas une
candidature ces 3 4 5 6 7 10 possibilité
de départ ou d'arrivée dans le
département donc en fait on a de ce
point de vue là un problème de riche
mais ça permet d'aller vraiment où on
veut après on a une autre contrainte qui
est la contrainte de notre taille et
j'évoquais tout à l'heure les 190 pays
qui reprennent le tour oui mais il ya
des journalistes oui mais il ya des
techniciens oui mais il ya des ddd
du matériel etc donc il faut parler de
300 candidatures donc je comprends bien
que les gens les élus se bousculent pour
y participer mais ce que parfois vous
êtes face aussi à des élus pour qui
c'est une c'est une vraie contrainte
c'est compliqué à gérer un passage du
tour de france d'être une étape du alors
je ne dirais pas ça parce qu'ils aient
une vraie envie en revanche dans notre
volonté d'aller dans des petites
communes parfois il peut y avoir une
peur mais une petite commune qui a peur
moi je ne suis pas inquiet une seule
seconde parce qu'on sait que les gens
vont tout faire nous accompagnons les
équipes qui sont sur place
le petit village il a une communauté de
communes une communauté voilà il ya un
département il ya une région et ils sont
aidés à tous points de vue et nous nous
les accompagnons vous savez les rassurer
ou j'ai peur où j'ai peur c'est quand
les gens n'ont pas peur
c'est pas du tout quand les gens ont
peur
ce qu'ils ne savent pas qu'ils ne savent
pas me font peur qu'ils
ne savent pas dans tout domaine me font
peur il reste que les gens aient peur
qu'ils soient inquiets non on les
accompagne il se passe toujours très
bien parce qu'on sait qu'ils vont tout
donner pour le tour il faut bien voir
que ce que ce que j'ai ressenti depuis
sept huit ans c'est une plus grande
fierté encore des gens à accueillir le
tour pourquoi d'après vous mais parce
que parfois il n'y a plus d'école plus
de maternité plus station service la
plus de possibilités pour aller chercher
des billets à la banque mais que le tour
de france lui vit encore
et vous ne pouvez pas imaginer à quel
point et on me dit merci parfois je me
dis je vais me faire engueuler
mais on me dit merci partout sur la
route du tour parce que les gens
existent tout d'un coup la ville le
village il est au centre de la carte
partout et on parle d'eux alors qu'on ne
parle plus d'eux on fait attention à eux
ça c'est pour moi quelque chose de très
intéressant qui parlent de cette france
un peu oublié c'est
encore une fois j'en reviens
la france vue d'en haut c'est ça le tour
ben on va partout donc on a une réalité
de la france qui est peut-être
différente de ce qu'on peut attendre par
ailleurs mais c'est juste une
photographie mais bien réelle et c'est
vrai qu'on vous surnomme le chirac nous
disons que nous sommes tellement bien
accueilli partout que si on n'a pas un
fois assez costaud et voilà parce que on
est tellement bien accueilli on nous
offre ce qui est mieux partout donc on
va pas faire moi je vais pas me j'aime
bien manger j'aime bien boire un coup
vous n'allez pas dire non ça n'est pas
pour moi mais ça ça veut dire en
revanche que deux mois avant le tour je
vais pas boire une seule goutte d'alcool
car nous après le tour je vais rien
boire que au 31 décembre vous me verrez
jamais prendre le champagne parce que
voilà il faut tenir la route entre
guillemets évidemment vous n'allez pas
dire non aux gens qui sont là qui sont
heureux de vous accueillir vous avez un
lien particulier avec ses élus de
terrain avec ses élus locaux c'est à
dire que
je les vois tellement se faire taper
dessus par qui d'une manière générale
ils sont critiqués en permanence quand
on dit le maire est abordé de bave c'est
la réalité de la vie et quand vous voyez
que ces gens qu'on considère ce quoi
comme des tricheurs soient au mieux
comme des incompétents donne dans un
monde qui ne donne plus il faut bien
voir que c'est sacrifier sa vie
familiale le plus souvent tous les
rendez vous les 3 5 10 20 30 rendez-vous
du week-end quasiment tous les week-ends
ça veut dire quelque chose ça pèse et
ces gens là le fond et la démocratie
pour moi c'est un système qui a encore
de l'avenir j'ose l'espérer j'ose
l'espérer donc ce contact là je l'avais
pas avant je savais pas mais quand on
passe de l'autre côté de journalistes
en face on est en face on voit des
choses qu'on n'imaginait pas on regarde
les gens différemment et du coup est ce
que ça veut dire que vous les avez senti
ses colères qui sont montés ces
dernières années ce que vous l'avez
perçu au fil de vos rencontres avec ses
élus locaux ou avec les habitants de ces
villages de cette france les colères non
la fierté oui et cette fierté la plus
grande elle venait sans doute d'un
manque par ailleurs oui donc la qualité
première peut-être pour un patron du
tour de france c'est d'aimer la france
dès mai les français c'est complètement
impossible d'être directeur du tour si
on n'aime pas la france si on n'aime pas
les gens d'une manière générale
je me souviens parce que nous
organisions aussi le tour de l'avenir le
tour de france des jeunes ya quelques
années et je me souviens d'une édition
en 2004 ou 2005 dans le cantal un
département que j'affectionne amorce la
petite nice du cantal et où le maire de
l'époque m'avait dit le petit déjeuner 8
heures sauf qu'au 18 heures c'est
tripous tête de veau omelette aux cèpes
et donc au bout de trois quarts d'heure
très bien ça m'allait très très bien et
au bout de trois quarts d'heure jeudi au
maire je vais y aller monsieur le maire
et il me regarde et est menée monsieur
n'aime pas ma cuisine et ils meurent
auxerre mais c'est symptomatique est
symbolique c'est à dire que les gens
sont heureux ils sont contents ils
veulent vous faire découvrir ce qu'ils
font de bien il vous propose le meilleur
bon ben voilà il faut savoir ça les
jambons la route du tour ce sont des
gens hyper gentil hyper sympa les élus
qui nous reçoivent aussi mais il faut
leur consacrer un tout petit peu de
temps même si on n'a pas de temps
paradoxalement mais c'est ce que je vois
avec les agriculteurs les agriculteurs
qui font beaucoup sur les paysages du
tour de france encore une fois que la
prise de vue aérienne parce que bien sûr
nos lacs de montagne le littoral ça
dépend pas d'eux mais la beauté des
terrains cultivés qui sont les gens ce
sont eux et ils font donc des fresques
etc et ils font c'est presque là à la
gloire du tour à un moment ils n'ont pas
le temps et pourtant ils consacrent
quand même du temps pour faire ça ou ça
formidable vous parlez de cette france
et ses français comme un
un élu comme un représentant politique
côté
[Rires]
non non non non non même si même si
j'apprécie l'excellentissime babaorum du
sénat soit sans aucun nom mais ce sont
ses contacts la crc découvrir des choses
qu'on ne soupçonne pas de voir des gens
qui se battent au quotidien pas pour eux
pour améliorer les choses peuvent se
tromper comme tout le monde on se trompe
tous mais il essaye et ça j'aurais vrai
que les français aient conscience au
moins deux ça se soit pas simplement la
caricature de celui ou de celle qui
triche il y en a qui trichent partout
dans tous les domaines et chez nous
aussi dans le cyclisme mais ça
représente pas l'ensemble et qu'au moins
on est conscient ce que des gens des
hommes et des femmes se battent si
demain il ya plus ces gens là on n'a
plus envie de faire ce qu'ils font qui a
envie de faire ce qu'ils font à eux qui
d'une certaine manière se sacrifie pour
le bien commun parce que c'est la
réalité pour la plupart et ça qui me
frappe et qui me fascine donc oui j'ai
j'ai beaucoup d'estimé d'attachement
pour l'ensemble de ses élus de terrain
bien sûr j'ai des photos pour vous
cristian preda
formidable à l'ordre mais moi je
découvre un petit peu je sais pas si je
prononce bien binyam germes est un jeune
erythréen vainqueur de gand wevelgem en
2022 pour ce cycliste qui se déroule en
belgique
il parle de son appétit pour les pavés
du nord il dit avoir pour mission de
développer le cyclisme sur le continent
africain est ce qu'il représente une
nouvelle génération de cyclistes qui
développe ou font la promotion du
cyclisme dans des continents ou des pays
où c'était pas le cas alors minime
kermesse qui vient d'avoir 22 ans est
formidable parce qu'effectivement voir
un coureur africain allé gagner sur les
pavés dans une des plus grandes courses
classiques d'un jour et danville gamme
c'est quelque chose d'inédit
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
auront lieu pour la toute première fois
en afrique en afrique noire au rwanda en
2025 il ya des coureurs qui arrivent
depuis plusieurs années etc mais qui
n'ont jamais eu ce talent là il était
aussi vice champion du monde espoirs
en octobre dernier en belgique geremek
donc c'est s'éteint c'est un coureur
tout jeune c'est un coureur pétri de
talent est bien évidemment contre cette
victoire-là son talent à lui et les
championnats du monde au rwanda en 2025
je rêve de l'émergence d'une nouvelle
génération
si vous savez mais bernard hinault
quintuple vainqueur du tour qui est
souvent allé sur la tropicale amissa
bongo au gabon me disais mais il ya des
gars formidable quand ils vont arriver
ça va être un déferlement voilà lui
c'est à ce jour la pépite la plus belle
des représentants du cyclisme africain
alors une photo un peu plus triste que
vous allez probablement reconnaître tout
de suite c'est vous lors d'un hommage à
fabio casartelli coureur cycliste
italien qui meurent sur le tour de
france en 95 lors d'une chute dans la
descente du col de portet d'aspet dans
les pyrénées c'était lors de la 15e
étape c'est l'un des souvenirs les plus
douloureux pour vous c'est ce que j'ai
lu vous concernant c'est vrai qu'on à
l'image des courses cyclistes comme d'un
spectacle bon enfant très familial très
joyeux vous en avez parlé de ces gens
sur le tour sur le terrain qui sourient
et en même temps ce sont aussi des
épreuves sportives dans lesquelles des
hommes perdent la vie
on a un problème de sécurité où vous
considérez que ça fait partie des
risques et ont
heureusement en
depuis 1903 en 3 trois coureurs sont
morts sur la route du tour
pas plus c'est déjà effrayant mais pas
plus moi je les ai vécus louis delluc
douloureusement puisque j'étais
journaliste à l'époque c'était le
premier tour que je couvrais pour enfin
à l'époque et je l' ai vu étendu sur la
route comme d'autres journalistes comme
des gens de l'organisation et c est la
manière dont ils étaient recroquevillés
en position de foetus avec le sens et
c'est le regard du médecin chef du tour
de france de l'époque gérard porte que
j'avais surpris en passant disait que
c'était très très grave
voire désespérée et malheureusement il
est mort jean marie leblanc mon
prédécesseur qui était un monsieur
absolument magnifique avait gardé dans
son bureau
deux choses seulement le maillot de
fabio casartelli qui était le champion
olympique c'était le champion olympique
trois ans avant il avait une femme un
petit gamin
est donc jean marie avait ce maillot là
il avait le maillot du pape avec ali
agça
l'homme qui avait voulu le tuer qui
était aussi le symbole de du pardon
d'une certaine manière je ne sais pas
jusqu'où chacun d'entre nous c'est très
individuelle est capable d'aller dans le
pardon j'en sais rien mais c'est un
élément essentiel dans la vie pour
chacun d'entre nous donc sur fabio
casartelli oui alors sage et je n'ai
jamais connu ça comme directeur
aussi parce que c'est un spectacle c'est
le spectacle dont on attend
vous savez je vais revenir un tout
récent le tour 2010 9 la seule fois où
une étape du tour a dû être interrompue
à cause du temps donc nous allions vers
tignes il ya eu des orages de grêle
terrible et puis derrière une coulée de
boue qui a coupé la route donc de toute
façon nous n'avions pas d'autre choix
que d'arrêter la course puisque
autrement le vainqueur aura été le
premier par terre et donc on a essayé
d'arrêter la course c'est à dire que à
radio tournon qui parle à tous les
véhicules ce qu'on appelle radio
toujours tous les véhicules toutes les
motos etc qui disent c'est terminé on a
pris les temps on s'arrête etc et les
coureurs ne l'entendait pas donc il a
fallu que la personne responsable de
radio tour puis thierry gouvenou notre
patron des compétitions 10 on arrête on
n'arrête rien ne bougeait donc j'ai dit
on envoie les motos ce qu'on appelle les
motos info donc le moteur qui va à côté
des coureurs de tête en dire mais on
arrête et il continué à descendre et j'y
suis allé moi-même ensuite et là d'un
seul coup on se dit les gars qu'on voit
prendre des risques parce que ça peut
monter à 90 95 cents à leur compteur
avec les pneus les boyaux des vélos qui
sont rien du tout même si ce sont des
funambules et dans ce coup je me suis
dit j'ai le sentiment qu'ils allaient
dix fois plus vite parce que je savais
que ça ne comptait plus et je me disais
mais les risques qu'ils prennent sont
affolants mais là on avait à faire enfin
ce sont des fauves en compétition donc
il ne voulait pas s'arrêter et et
j'avais dis donc à l'un des deux
coureurs qui étaient qui était devant un
britannique qui est souillée mais les
tentes étaient présents unis mais je
m'en fous moi le classement général ne
m'intéresse pas je veux gagner l'étape
il a fallu vrillé et quand nous avons
arrêté cette étape là je me suis
précipité ensuite vers les courts pour
leur montrer les photos parce qu'il ne
pleuvait pas quand on a arrêté le ciel
était très loin au fond mais eux ne le
voyait pas il se demandait pourquoi on
arrêtait j'ai montré les photos de la
route et ils ont fait à aa ce que je
savais qu'avec la photo il comprendrait
tout de suite pourquoi on arrêtait mais
sur le coup c'est très compliqué on va
s'arrêter sur une dernière question
christian prudhomme c'est une question
qui est un rituel dans cette émission je
sais pas si vous l'avez remarqué nous
sommes entourés de quatre magnifiques
statut qui représentent chacune une
vertu vous avez derrière vous la sagesse
la prudence ici la justice est derrière
moi l'éloquence est ce qu'il ya une de
ses vertus qui vous parle
particulièrement oui la sagesse sans
aucun doute même si mon nom prud'hommes
irait plutôt vers prudence mais mais
mais la sagesse de justement ne pas
oublier ce qu'on fait les gens avant
tout de savoir que nous ne sommes que
des gens qui transmettent est ce que
m'avait dit jean marie leblanc tu es là
pour transmettre mes fait le du mieux
possible les champions ce sont eux les
héros sans aucun doute demain à nouveau
demain à nouveau les championnes aussi
parce qu'il faut que les petits gars me
demande la route puisse s'identifier aux
championnes et ça j'y tiens beaucoup
mais oui la sagesse
dans un monde qui est qui en manquent
cruellement il faut bien le dire et ce
sera le mot de la fin merci merci
christian prudence l'a été avec nous
dans un monde un regard merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve très
vite sur public sénat
[Musique]